I'm gonna talk to you guys this
afternoon about building scalable
stateful services okay
so um I'm kidding McCaffrey if you don't
know me I'm a distributed systems
engineer I currently work at Twitter and
I'm the tech lead for observability
there and then prior to that in a former
life I spent a really long time working
in the games industry on a variety of
different games building out services
that powered those experiences so what
I'm going to talk to you guys today is
some lessons learned in building
stateful services and not databases and
caches but actually bringing state into
our actual services and the benefits and
why we may want to do that and why it's
beneficial moving forward oh that's like
me on the Internet I will talk to you on
the Internet so if you want to do that
hit me up so we've been in this paradigm
of programming state less services and
this has worked really well for about
the last five to ten years and we like
your service is stateless and so then as
you get more clients or customers or
users of your API you just add another
service and you scale out horizontally
and this works pretty well and we use
these databases that we talk to to store
the canonical source of truth to be our
history to be like the you know the the
rock and are in our system that stored
all of our states so that our services
didn't have to think about it and this
works okay and did for a while but the
problem is is like our services do have
state the applications we're building
have state and we've been you relying on
this abstraction if it's all like
covered in this database and that gave
us really strong consistency but we
started to hit these limits where one
database doesn't cut it anymore and so
we've gone into this no sequel world or
we were or were sharding you know
relational databases and we're giving up
some of these more strongly consistent
properties and this abstraction of all
of the data living and being taken care
of by the database is leaky now it's
leaking into our services because what
we're actually doing when we have these
states we have state that we're using in
stateless services is we have a client
making a request in the data shipping
paradigm and so I go to the database and
it sends me some data back and then I
answer the request and then I'm going to
return
the result and then this data that I
transferred over the network is just
gonna go away and then the next time the
client makes a similar request operating
on a similar set of data it's gonna do
the exact same thing but it got load
balance to a different machine this time
and so now we've like God and pulled the
same data across the network onto a
different machine to answer the request
for the same user and then it gets
thrown away again and so this can keep
going on and on and so for applications
where we have these chatty clients that
are operating over a session over a
duration or a period of time like think
in games think in any of these
applications where it's doing something
for you like ordering a car or tracking
your fitness workout or your like
communication something about your state
or your location to the service you're
mostly just talking about yourself
because we all like to talk about
ourselves and so these applications are
operating on the same set of state and
like pulling them into all these
different services load balancing
between can be pretty wasteful so I'm
going to talk to you about how you might
want to think about building state full
services and some of the benefits you
can get from them and I'm gonna caveat
this upfront this is not like a magic
panacea that you want to use all the
time stateless services are still
incredibly effective in horizontal
scalability is something that you still
want to be able to do but you can get
some really nice benefits well then talk
about how you want to go and build these
and start thinking about the trade-offs
you're gonna have to make while building
them and then we'll give you some
real-world examples of some cool systems
they're actually running in production
today and doing very well that have
become a stateful for a variety of
different reasons and then I'll give you
a quick cautionary like road map of
things you might want to watch out for
that are different than building state
less services so if you try to do this
at home these are things that pop up
that you may not think about okay so the
big benefit I see in state full services
is you have data locality so data
locality is this idea that you ship the
request to the machine that holds the
data to operate on it and I want to do
this for a couple reasons one I get low
latency I don't have to go and hit the
database which is the canonical source
of truth still probably at a service
every single time I just have to hit it
whenever I don't happen to have the
state I need on
machine and then so it's providing lower
latency because we're doing less Network
calls it's also really great for data
intensive applications where a client
needs to operate over a bunch of data
and like have very quick response times
so this is relying on the function
shipping paradigms this is the idea of
if a client makes a request or starts a
session we still have to go to the
database the first time to get the data
and it moves into our service but then
once that request has been handled we
leave that data on the service and then
the next time the client makes a very
similar request which is gonna operate
on that data it just has to talk to the
same machine that it just that it
already pulled the data on to and then
this way I don't have to go to my
database I'm not actually adding extra
latency image my databases down I can
still handle this request right and then
the same thing happens like over and
over again as long as I keep not needing
to go back to the database as long as I
can talk to the same machine that my
data already lives on this is a nice
world to live in another benefit of
stateful services if you build them
using sticky connections is you can get
more available consistency models and
I'll sort of walk through this so I
think we're all pretty familiar with the
cap theorem this is the idea that you
have consistency availability and
partition tolerance pick two you don't
not get to pick partition tolerance
because physics and so in a in this
world when we have different levels of
consistency that we operate against some
are not available or not highly
available right like they have our CP
systems they are only on offered under
CP systems and then if we want to have
highly available forms of consistency
you basically get right from reading
monotonic read and monotonic right this
is sort of like an induction tree but if
we have sticky connections where the
data for from a single user and like in
the single model is always talking to
the same machine then you can have these
other consistency models that are
stronger consisting guarantees like read
your rights pipeline random access
memory and causal consistency are a bit
like AP in the CapSense and so this is
actually really nice one of the first
times I sort of came across this idea
was a blog post that Werner Vogel wrote
in 2007 from Amazon entitled eventual
consistency
see revisited and so he starts talking
about building sticky connections in the
sense of like Amazon's Amazon DynamoDB
and the one of the points that he makes
in addition to these consistency models
is you're giving your clients sort of a
nicer framework to reason about instead
of having to think about oh my data may
be pulled into all these different
machines and all this crazy concurrency
is having on if you just have your
client talking to the same server
because you have a sticky connection
it's a little easier to reason about so
it helps us out when we're programming
distributed systems models okay so so
those are some of the benefits let's
talk about how you may want to go about
building these so that you can take
advantage of data locality so you might
be able to take advantage of some of
these better consistency models that it
and still be available so the the basic
idea behind a CV connection is it is
exactly what it sounds like we have a
client who's going to make a request to
a cluster of servers and they're always
going to get routed to the same server
somehow they're always going to talk to
the same server for their session or
whatever the duration of what you're
doing is going on so the dumbest and
easiest to implement way is just to open
up a persistent connection so this could
be you know you open up a persistent
HTTP request or you open up a persistent
tcp channel or pick your protocol of
choice it's super easy to implement so
then you'll always be sent to the same
machine because you're always talking to
that machine over the same connection
for the length of the session however it
does have some problems associated with
it obviously once the connection breaks
the stickiness is gone and you're gonna
get like round-robin to another server
but the bigger problem here I think and
that I've actually encountered in
production that's caused outages is load
balancing when you do this you're
essentially making an assumption that
all of these sessions all these sticky
connections sort of last for the same
amount of time and are gonna cause your
seat or your conservator talking to you
the same amount of load and that's not
generally the case so what you need to
do you can easily overwhelm a single
server by having a persistent connection
to many persistent connections sort of
dogpile on one server that are very
expensive or last for a really long time
or doing a ton of work because you just
happen to have a bunch of chatty clients
and that machines gonna like go down
real hard if you do not implement back
pressure so I highly recommend or would
say it's a requirement
building persistent connections that you
need to implement back pressure on these
machines so that they can break
connections when they're overwhelmed
this way the client then has to
reconnect um you could also in addition
do some smarter load balancing logic to
say like hey connect to a machine that
has like the most resources free but you
still need back pressure that's like a
bare minimum requirement for persistent
connections if you want to do something
a little smarter and oh this this is
more beneficial you can implement some
routing logic in your cluster so this is
the idea that a client can talk to any
server in the cluster and then it will
be routed to the server that has its
data that's going to answer its requests
where it's going to perform its
computation and there's two sort of
categories of problems I think about
when solving routing logic in services
is you have cluster membership who is in
my cluster and like how do I determine
like what machines are actually
available to be talked to and then work
distribution how am I going to
distribute load across this cluster
right and so we're going to go through
those because there's actually a variety
of different choices and they have
different impacts and trade-offs with
them so once again the dumbest thing you
can do the easiest thing you can do
which sometimes works right like I'm
always a big fan of starting with the
dumbest thing possible and then seeing
if it meets your needs is using static
cluster memberships this is literally
like a config file that you deploy in
your cluster that has all the addresses
of the nodes and the machines in it and
this works for certain scenarios
although it does have problems it's not
super fault tolerant so if a machine
goes down you essentially have to
replace that machine if you want to
expand a cluster from an Operations
perspective this becomes incredibly
painful because you essentially have to
take down the entire cluster and then
bring it back up in order to do the load
balancing correctly or in order to do
the work distribution correctly oops
sorry
animations so what's going on here is
that this is easy to do but it's
operationally painful and it's also not
a great choice for services that have to
be highly available where you can't
tolerate downtime where you have really
strict SLA s so sort of the next better
thing you can do is dynamic cluster
membership and so this is just the idea
that I
add and remove nodes on the fly from the
cluster and then when I just want to
because of failure or I want to add
capacity they'll just get added to the
cluster and they'll start immediately
taking load and vice versa if one fails
or you know one needs to you can reduce
capacity for whatever is in so there's
sort of two main big ways of doing
dynamic cluster membership that I've
seen work there's gossip protocols so
this is the idea that it's a protocol
design where the machines are gonna chat
just like you sort of would with your
friends and knowledge spreads throughout
a social group and they're gonna chat
about who they can talk to you and who's
alive and who's dead and then each
machine on its own will figure out its
worldview of who it thinks is in the
cluster and so it's just deciding based
on the messages that it happens to have
received and in sort of like a stable
state or a non failure mode environment
we're not a lot of churn is happening
all of the machines in the cluster will
stabilize to have the same worldview of
everyone being who's alive is alive and
everyone who's dead is dead in the case
where you have a bunch of network
failures capacity is being added or like
you have a partition in your network
different machines in the cluster can
actually have different world views of
who is in the cluster so this causes a
bit this is like one of the trade-offs
that you need to make with dynamic
cluster membership is if you want high
availability right like these machines
don't have to coordinate to figure out
who's in the cluster they can each
independently make a decision based on
the knowledge that they currently have
then then you use a gossip protocol but
your code and your applications need to
be able to tolerate this partition or
this uncertainty where work may be
getting routed to different nodes for
brief periods of time during failure
conversely if you need really strong
consistency and sort of cluster
membership like everyone needs to have
exactly the same worldview you want to
use a consensus system to do this and so
you just you know you do this like in a
typical way you interact with the
consensus system it controls the
ownership of everyone who's in the
cluster and then when that changes like
everyone goes and updates their
worldview based on the consensus system
that's holding the truth of like cluster
membership the problem with this is that
once again if that consensus system
isn't available the nodes can actually
route work because they don't know who's
in the
stur it's also going to be slower right
because you're adding coordination to
your system so sort of like Peter valus
talked about right like we sort of want
to avoid this unless we necessarily need
it so I would sort of say this is the
last resort when you're designing
dynamic cluster membership if you need
highly available systems and then
finally I want to talk the second
problem is work distribution right and
there's a couple of different methods
I'm gonna go through three there's
random placement consistent hashing and
distributed hash tables for determining
how to move work throughout your cluster
random placement sounds super dumb but
it actually can be really effective in
certain scenarios so this is the idea of
I get to write to anywhere in the
cluster so when I'm sending you're right
from my client any machine that has
capacity just takes it and then on read
I go and I have to actually read from
every single machine in the cluster to
get the data back so this isn't actually
a sticky connection but it is a stateful
service in the sense of this is a good
way to build like in-memory indexes and
caches and I'll actually get to a
real-world example that does this and
like how it's used in the real world
because it sort of sounds stupid if
you're looking at just this example it's
hard to understand like why it would
ever work but it is nice where you have
a lot of data and your queries are
operating a large amount of data that is
gonna be distributed over the entire
cluster I think one that is probably
more familiar to people is consistent
hashing this came out of a paper in 1997
from the World Wide Web about how to
distribute workloads the basic idea here
is you have deterministic placement of
your requests and we've now mapped our
nodes that are in the cluster to the
same hash space as the requests that are
coming in and so your hashing your
request based on like whatever the
session ID is or whatever the user ID is
depending how you want to partition your
workload and so then you just add the
nodes get mapped to the cluster and then
as a request comes in it also gets
hashed on to the ring and then you walk
right to find the node that's actually
going to execute it for you this is
really popular a lot of databases use
this so like Amazon DynamoDB uses this
Twitter's Manhattan database uses this I
believe Cassandra uses this this is
pretty pretty basic database we
distribution because it is deterministic
placement but the problem with the
termina stick placement especially in
services where users are coming and
going and I don't necessarily need to
keep your data in memory all of the time
like a database does the problem with
this is that you can have hotspots right
you can run into the same problem where
if your requests are not like evenly
distribute or even if they are evenly
distributed because this is a hash they
actually have different different
weights in terms of like the amount of
work that they're gonna do based on like
what each user wants to request and so
you could easily end up with a hot node
or you could just have a node that's
kind of slow in your cluster and so like
it's gonna get overwhelmed for a variety
of reasons because like you know maybe
it's discs or going bad or whatever
there's like a but should think
different things that can happen and so
this does not allow you to move work if
a machine gets overloaded so you have to
allocate enough space in your cluster to
run with enough Headroom to like
tolerate the fact that this is
deterministic and you can't move work so
you're paying an additional cost to have
extra capacity sitting around even in
the normal case so finally I wanna talk
about distribute hash tables for work
just placement so the idea here is that
I'm going to use a hash again to look up
into a distributed hash table where I
should execute this work and so that
what happens is then I just look at this
holds a reference to the node that I'm
gonna go talk to you that's in my
cluster and then if this is this is
non-deterministic placement right
because there's nothing that's forcing
me to always go to note a I could easily
remap this client in my system to go to
node B or node C should note a become
too hot or unavailable for some reason
and so this actually has a lot of nice
properties and I'll get to an example in
the real world where this works very
well
okay so let's talk about stateful
services in the real world I'm gonna
give you an overview of free that I
think are particularly interesting and
that's sort of exhibit a the range of
some of the stuff that we just talked
about in terms of different ways you can
configure and build your cluster out so
scuba is from Facebook
it's an in-memory database that they
built and basically this is its this
runs a lot of the workhorse for their
query and analytics and revenue and
performance debugging and has to be very
very fast and has to be always available
because they're doing things like on the
fly right and so and I believe they use
static cluster membership although I
don't think the paper actually says that
but from what I've inferred from what
I've seen I think it's static cluster
membership so basically what happens is
they do this random fan-out on right so
it's gonna write to any machine that
happens to have it and then it's going
to on read query every single machine in
the cluster when it's executing a query
and then they're going to then all these
results come back in they get composed
by the machine that's like running the
query and then when the results are
returned to the user a completeness
metric is also returned so what's cool
about this is like in order to get 100%
of the data and to know that your query
actually executed correctly and you have
all the results every machine in the
cluster would have to be available but
like we live in a real world and that's
never the case and so what they did is
they built this in from the start to say
I'm gonna tell the the requester what
percentage of data that I have been able
to successfully retrieve data from and
then this allows them to decide if
that's acceptable amount of uncertainty
and so I think that's actually really
really cool there's a paper on scuba if
you want to go read more but this is
actually a pretty neat system so they're
not using sticky but they connections
that they are using in memory for very
very fast data lookups another really
interesting stateful service that is
sort of come out in the last year is
over built this thing called Ring Pop
and what it is is it's an odious library
that allows them to do sort of like
application layers charting for their
dispatcher platform services and so the
reason they built this is because if you
think about what the app is doing like
when you're ordering a car is it
talking to the service and it's gonna
like send your information and your
location and then throughout the
duration of the ride it's gonna send you
more
you're gonna update it with your
location and information and then it has
to process a bunch of payment and your
drivers stuff and if you were getting
load balance to different servers every
single time and that data was constantly
being persisted to the database and then
pulled back in on every request that's a
ton of latency on the service and it's a
ton of extra load on the database so
what they did is they went and
implemented routing logic into this
cluster and so that they can have all of
your requests for your session directed
to a single machine and so they do this
via using the swim gossip protocol for
cluster membership right so this is this
is an AP customer membership thing so
it's not always guaranteed to be totally
correct but they made the choice to
always be available because they'd
rather have you be able to order a car
then like to tell you like sorry we
can't deal with this cuz leg zookeepers
down and then they also use consistent
hashing for doing work distribution
throughout the cluster and so once again
this has the problem where you can have
hot nodes and there's really nothing you
can do except for add more capacity to
the cluster in that case even if you
have a bunch of nodes that are
underutilized this is a really cool
project I highly recommend checking it
out it's open source on github and there
have been a couple extra talks and stuff
around it if you want to know more
finally I want to talk about Arlene's
so Arlene's is a programming model and
runtime for building distributed systems
based on the actor model this came out
of Microsoft research from the extreme
computing group there and I actually had
the pleasure of working with this group
to productionize Arlene's when we
shipped halo 4 so we rebuilt all of the
halo 4 services primarily based on
Arlene's and I've talked about Arlene's
before and I've talked about the actor
model before and I'm just gonna give you
a quick overview so if you are
unfamiliar that you understand what's
happening but really I want to talk
about the routing logic in the system
because it's very cool and it's sort of
how our leans does a lot of its magic so
it's actually happening an actor/model
is this idea for concurrent computation
where actors are the core unit of
computation actors can communicate with
one another by passing asynchronous
messages to each other throughout the
cluster and when an actor receives an
asynchronous message it can do one of
three things
or all of them it can send new messages
or as many as it once it can update its
journals in its internal state and it
can create new actors so essentially
what you end up having in a cluster
running in any kind of actor model is a
bunch of little state machines that are
running and so you are inherently
building stateful services when you're
using the actor model if they are
persisting any state between requests
and we use this very heavily at halo we
use them like in a little in memory
right through caches so how this
actually works though is we just deploy
a bunch of machines and Orleans runtime
takes care of the rest and so when we
got a request it would go to any machine
in the cluster and then the cluster
would actually look up where the actor
lived in the cluster and wrap that
message to it and there's like thousands
hundreds of thousands of actors on any
clock on any single machine in the
cluster so the way they do this is that
use a gossip protocol for cluster
membership because we chose to be highly
available there's actually I think now
that Orleans has been open sourced a
zookeeper implementation of cluster
membership but that's slower and so
you're not going to get the performance
benchmarks that are outlined in the
Orleans paper um and then it for work
distribution it does this interesting
combination of consistent hashing and a
distributed hash table that I'm going to
walk through because I just think it's
neat and I haven't seen many other real
world systems use this so this is our
aleene's cluster we have six machines
and then there's a bunch of actors
running on any machine I'm gonna get a
request from a client that says hey I
need to send a message to this actor in
this ID and so then what a releases
runtime is going to do is apply a
consistent hash to that actor ID and
that's going to tell it where the
distributed hash table for that ID is
located in the cluster so I'm gonna go
and then go to the machine that has the
distributed hash table entry for my
actor this will then tell me which
machine my actor physically lives on and
then the request can get routed to that
machine so this is this is cool because
the consistent hashing part where you're
doing the distributed hash table lookup
is deterministic and so that's going to
be consistent throughout the lifetime of
and after and in the cluster it's not
going to change but this is okay because
when you think about a distributed hash
table like you're just storing the key
which is the actor ID and the Machine
look
which is just an address and it's the
same for every single node in the
cluster so this is like actually very
evenly distributed and balanced workload
however what our actors are doing is not
necessarily evenly distributed in
balance because even different types of
actors can run in Orleans clusters and
so we wanted to make sure that if a
machine becomes hot or leans can help
like rebalance the cluster for you so
what happens is say that machine got too
hot or the session died and then the
client comes in the same client comes in
it'll ask like hey I need to talk to
this my actor again and so it'll get
routed to the same distributed hash
table or the same node it's piece of the
distributed hash table and then that
know the dish read hash table entry has
now changed the aleene's cluster has
actually updated it to say hey it's now
on this machine and it does that for a
couple of reasons one like the machine
that you were talking to you before
failed or the machine the actor you were
talking to you before got like evicted
from memory because no one was talking
to it for a while or you your machine
was running way too hot and Arlene's
decided hey I'm gonna move this for you
so that machine doesn't get overwhelmed
and fall over and I'm gonna use some of
this capacity that's not being used on
this other machine this is one of the
core reasons that we were able to run
our lanes clusters in production at 90
to 95 percent CPU utilization across the
cluster so we were using the entire box
because we were able to move work around
in a non-deterministic fashion so I
think that was pretty cool and I think
it's like I would not recommend doing
this for like a database but it is
really neat when you start thinking
about pulling state into services okay
so finally I'm gonna talk about some
things that are how you might run into
trouble or like gotchas that you might
not think of because you've been
building stateful or stateless services
for a long time so I think we all know
or we should all know that unbounded
queues are essentially like the devil
and distributed systems and will like
kill you really really fast because
you're making implicit assumptions in
state full services unbounded data
structures like in-memory data
structures on the box are like are this
bad they will like hurt you really
really fast because and we don't
generally think about this I think in
state less services because if you bound
your inputs on any request then you're
saying it's assuming that you're
processing a reasonable
sized amount of data on every request
and then that data structure you create
for that request is generally garbage
collected or evicted from memory at the
end of that request when you have state
full services and you're persisting a
bunch of stuff over over a span of
requests you need to put an explicit
bound on here because these could grow
you know unbounded Li and then you run
on a memory on your machine or your
garbage collector gets really sad and
decides it's gonna stop the world and
garbage collects for a really long time
and then that node essentially looks
dead so this is something that you sort
of have to work out I've actually seen
production machines go down because this
assumption that like we would never run
out of memory and our clients would only
a send us a reasonable amount of things
over a stretch of a session like didn't
happen cuz clients are not your friends
they're not gonna do what you want them
to you're also gonna have to deal with
memory management and you do have to
deal with this in stateless service to
some extent but you don't have to tune
generally as much so basically because
we're in a stateful world and we're
persisting data for the lifetime or for
the lifetime of the session which could
be you know minutes hours whatever days
even things are going to get persisted
into the lowest center or the the
longest live generation of garbage
collection so like g2 and the CLR and so
at this point that's generally more
expensive to collect especially if you
have a bunch of references that are
spanning generations of your garbage
collector that's gonna get really
expensive to collect and so you sort of
have to understand stateful services and
be aware of how your garbage collector
is actually running or you could just
say totally I'm not gonna even worry
about it and go and implement unmanaged
code like scuba is all in C++ I believe
and so they like don't even deal with
the garbage collector problem so like
Orleans runs dotnet CLR and so that is
the garbage collected thing we did run
into this problem but we were able to
work with our garbage collector and tune
it and also realize we were just
persisting a lot of state that we never
used and so we sort of cleaned up our
requests but you have to be a little
more careful about what you actually are
persisting because this does have an
Associated cost with it
and then finally the sort of last Gacha
is this idea of reloading state
typically like in state less services
you're going to go to the database every
single time and so you tune your latency
to be acceptable based on like having a
round trip right or you stick a cache in
there to make it better in state full
services there's actually a variety of
different cases you can have the first
connection of this session so that's
actually generally gonna be your most
expensive connection because there is no
data in in anywhere in your service
because it's probably been evicted if
someone hasn't been talking to you for a
while or ever before so you have to go
get all this data from the database you
have to pull it in so that they can
start answering this the startup request
and this could take a long time unless
you're careful you want to be very
selective about what you load on startup
because you want it to look as close to
normal requests as possible the best way
to sort of benchmark and test this is to
use percentiles very heavily because
your average request latency is actually
gonna look really really good because
you don't have to round-trip to the
database every single time once you've
loaded it into memory and so but and you
will really only detect that your first
connection startup time is really long
if you use percentiles another sort of
gotcha with first connections is
typically with state less services I'm
going to make a request and if the
request times out because I'm taking too
long to talk to the database I'm then
just going to like cancel the requests
on the database and not pull that state
into memory but with state full services
you know the clients going to come back
and ask you for that data like you know
right away again
and so you might as well just keep
pulling it into memory even if the first
request has failed and that client has
timed out because then they're just
gonna ask for it again on a retry and it
will get routed to the same machine and
then the data will just be there and it
will be fast so like typically in Halo
we had this issue where I think on games
startup sometimes like the first
connection would actually timeout and so
we just kept pulling the data in from
the database and then the next time the
game box actually retried it would
succeed if we're talking you know like
hundreds of milliseconds of time and
this actually wasn't user noticeable
especially since there was a really
pretty animation playing on the screen
for them to watch and so then by the
time it was like distract and then we
got to do our things on the services and
so-and-so them by the time they came
back the second time we just kept
pulling the data that we needed
especially if it was like a player who
had played a lot or we had tunnel load B
just because our azor table we were like
stressing that connection this worked
really really well for us
another thing that's gonna cause
problems in terms of like reloading
state is recovering from a crash so if
you have to like rehydrate an entire box
after recovering from a crash that could
be expensive if you're not just like
lazily loading everything and sometimes
you can get away with lazy loading and
sometimes you can't and then in the same
instant wave deploying new code you're
gonna have this problem or you have to
put take down an entire box and bring up
a whole nother box and if you can't in
like not a terminus tically place things
or you don't have dynamic clusters
membership then this is also gonna cause
problems for you so one interesting way
to solve this that we sort of came
across was or that I've come across is
that Facebook published a paper called
fast restarts at Facebook and this was
actually designed for their scuba system
because they had the same problem they
had this in memory database that was
holding like a ton of memory in data
that was persisted to hard disk and so
on a rack rack or on a deploy they would
like take down the machine the process
that was currently running and they
would spin up a new machine and then
they would have to read everything from
disk and this took hours like per
machine and because of their SL lays
they had to do a very slow rolling
restart of the entire cluster that took
I think up to 12 hours so this is gonna
slow your development team down a lot
there's not a whole lot you can do to
get away from that on a crash restart
but hopefully that happens fairly
infrequently deploying code though
happens really really frequently or we'd
like to tap in frequently because it
allows us to iterate faster and try new
ideas and do less risky deployments so
they made this key observation that you
can actually decouple the memory
lifetime of a process especially or
memory lifetime from the process
lifetime especially in a state full
service right so when they want to just
deploy new code and they knew it was a
safe shutdown in memory wasn't corrupted
because like I told the process to
shutdown it didn't crash then they would
stop taking requests they would actually
copy all of the data from the current
running process into shared memory and
they would shut down the old process and
bring up the new process which would
then copy the data from shared memory
back into like the processes memory
space and then they would start taking
requests this took minutes and so they
got their cluster research that time
below down to like two
this allows them to deploy much more
frequently than they were able to before
so that's I think just like a really
easy trick that is really cool and we're
actually looking at implementing it on
one of the services that my team is
responsible for at Twitter because we
have sort of like an index that does is
very stateful and when you have to
restart a whole machine have to go and
talk to our Manhattan database and
that's really slow right
compared to memory so in conclusion I
hope I've sort of painted a picture of
why you may want to start bringing state
into your actual services and not just
relying on your databases there are some
really nice properties like data
locality and available consistent more
available consistency mechanisms that
you can get there is a ton of thought
that needs to be put into cluster
membership and work distribution and I
don't have one right answer for you
although I tend to lean very much
towards the available side so I would go
with gossip protocols and then work
distribution it's really going to depend
on the workload that you're using there
are a bunch of these successful stateful
real world systems out there that are
running and so like it's been proven at
scale that you can do this and so it's
not necessarily super scary although it
is new ground and then finally be
cautious this is new territory if you
haven't done staple services before go
through what is different what has
changed what assumptions are you making
and make sure you make them explicit and
then finally I have a sort of like this
is new space and like people aren't
doing this so should I even bother
reading papers yes yes you should
because most of what I have talked about
has actually just come from database
literature and so this problems are
already solved for you and you don't
have to actually even be like the nice
thing about implementing services you
get to cherry-pick what you care about
based on your application state and so
you don't even have to go and implement
the whole paper you can just pick the
piece of the paper that you like and
that problem is probably solved for you
so I highly recommend reading papers do
not reinvent your own protocols this is
actually not new territory people have
been working on this since like the 60s
and 70s um finally I want to say thank
you to some people who helped me out
with this talk Kyle Kingsbury Chris
Mikkel John Thompson Taryn eNOS Umbra
thank you guys so much for all of your
help and I that is all I have for you so
I think we have time for like one
question
you